Vous avez vu ?
Oui, c'est marrant. On a un petit gars, syndiqué. Il travaille là-haut toute la journée.
Si je le fais au ralenti, si ça va directement,
ça tombe près de votre poche. C'est bien dans cette poche, monsieur ?
Non, ne mettez pas la main dans la poche. C'est un autre genre d'émission.
Donc – (couinements) – c'est curieux. Ça se soigne.
Puis-je leur montrer ce que c'est ? C'est curieux. C'est à vous, monsieur ?
Je ne sais pas du tout comment ça marche. On va le mettre là-bas.
Parfait. J'ai besoin d'aide pour ce tour-ci.
Faites un pas par ici.
Ne vous échappez pas. Vous aviez quelque chose dans votre poche de pantalon.
J'ai vérifié la mienne. Je n'ai rien trouvé,
mais j'ai remarqué que vous aviez quelque chose.
Je peux tâter votre poche de l'extérieur un instant ?
Là, j'ai remarqué ça. Ça vous appartient, monsieur ?
Ceci ? Je n'en sais rien. C'est une crevette.
Joe: Ouais, je la garde pour plus tard.
AR: Vous avez été un merveilleux artiste pour tous ces gens,
plus que vous ne pourriez le penser.
Nous sommes très heureux de vous remettre cette belle montre en cadeau. (Rires)
J'espère qu'elle est à son goût.
Mais on a également d'autres choses,
un peu de liquide, et encore d'autres babioles.
Tout cela vous appartient,
tout comme ces applaudissements de la part de tous vos amis. (Applaudissements)
Joe, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, je vous pose la même question que précédemment,
mais cette fois, inutile de fermer les yeux.
Qu'est-ce que je porte ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
L'attention est quelque chose de puissant.
Comme je l'ai dit, ça façonne votre réalité.
Donc, je voudrais vous poser cette question.
Si vous pouviez contrôler l'attention de quelqu'un,
qu'en feriez-vous ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)